I cooked! I made it nice!
All right, at least I don't do crystal meth
in the bathroom all night long, b****.
Just because you can doesn't mean you should, girl.
You have a little family van.
- So you want to fight? Let's go.
- Got it!
Enough!
Surprise!
That's my opinion!
Blue Stone Manor is a very special place.
If you enter those doors, something happens.
- Aahhh!
- Oohhh!
Pajama party!
Woooo!
Why did I just realize that none of us
are no longer on any of our shows?
Ex-wives club.
We're the ex-wives club!
Here we are.
What do you do here?
Aahhh!
- Get off!
- Get me out of here!
We are destroying this town.
Aahhh!
I'm very turned on right now.
Do you want to go to a naked party?
Woooooo!
Bye bye, peasants!
Where do you have to go
to whoop it up around here at?
I can't get dick!
Oohhh!
Face of an angel, mouth of a serpent.
How liquor make people act like this.
I don't like it.
When my bubble bursts,
I burst back.
You tell the truth, a unicorn is going to show up.
Birds of a feather flock together.
I am not flocking with that bird.
Could you shut the f*** up?
No, you shut the f*** up.
I won't tell you anything anymore
about my relationship, how's that?
I was on a show that you're no longer on.
How do you feel? I love you.
Stop! F****** b****!
I am social distancing from the b*******.
I can't go to another hospital with you.
It's giving me a mangina.
What the f*** is a mangina?
Don't be a liar.
I'm gonna walk away because I'm about to get-
You know, she does a book, it's a lie.
We are fighting about stuff I did.
There's a lot of conflict going on with eight women.
The only conflict is you.
What made you think the lady was a lesbian?
Her eyebrows.
Hahahaha!
These women are nuts!
It's like when pit girls get their periods together.
Ha! That ship has sailed.
Vicky, I want to show you how to use a vibrator.
I might have to pee my pants again.
To the ex-wives club!
Gotta stop calling people b******.
One rotten apple to spoil the whole barrel.
- Aahhh!
- Haha!
Life is but a f****** dream.